Three Two One Go
[Musik]
Das ist die Welt des Wettkampfessens
und das sind die Leute, die
ihr Leben dafür einsetzen, es
in dieser wachsenden Szene zu schaffen. Sie ist
im Moment massiv, sie wird definitiv
größer,
jetzt wird sie zunehmend als
Sport angesehen  Snooker ist ein
absolut konkurrenzfähiger Sport, da sie
in wenigen Minuten Berge von Lebensmitteln
und Tausende von Kalorien in einer einzigen
Sitzung
essen können. Wettkampfessen wurde als eine
der am schnellsten wachsenden Sportarten der Welt bezeichnet.
Was muss dies mit ihrem Körper tun
und wie können sie möglicherweise  Bleiben Sie gesund
, was während einer Herausforderung in Ihrem Magen vor sich geht